palestinians turned out in force to pay
tribute to the slain Palestinian
teenager an official investigation is
underway but most here believe Israeli
extremists murdered the 16 year old boy
to avenge the deaths of three Israeli
teenagers abducted earlier this year at
the funeral the boy's mother fainted
falling to the ground and masked men
vowed to exact revenge lacuna was
thought I have a message we will respond
by any means and God willing this will
be Israel's last assault our response
will be powerful vaada raha [ __ ] fell on
coffee honey naughty boy is a martyr we
are honored by his death but it also
saddens us because he died at the hands
of Israelis
the funeral also took on a symbolic
character because it coincided with the
first friday prayers of Ramadan
protesters clashed with Israeli security
forces at numerous points during the
funeral procession mass used threw rocks
and police responded with stun grenades
dozens were injured on Thursday
demonstrators rallied in support of
Islamist militant group Hamas sources
say Egypt has stepped in to broker a
ceasefire Israel is stationed tanks and
ground troops along the Gaza border the
government has promised harsh
retaliation is Hamas attacks